hi i'm kelly tran and i play raya hi i'm
daniel day kim and i play chief benja hi
i'm aquafina and i play sisu hi this is
benedict wong
and i play paul hi i'm sandra oh and i
play
virana hi i'm gemma chan and i play
namari
today we're with buzzfeed take a quiz to
find out which character from
our movie raya and the last dragon we
actually are
if you were a dragon in kumandra what
special
ability would you desire fog rain
shape-shifting glow super swimming
or to be honest just being a dragon is
enough for me thanks
i'm gonna go with shape-shifting on this
one i think that's the coolest one what
are you what are you guys thinking
shape-shifting for me i'm with you yeah
yeah
i'm not telling you i'm not telling you
oh okay
like that all right well it i think i
think for me just being a dragon is just
enough
you know what i mean you know i think
that's that's really what i think that's
what it is
you're such a humble dragon
the weather's so terrible in england
i've just gone for glow
that's what we need shape shifting
i just have my zoom face on when people
figure out no no it's good
[Laughter]
it's like my parents i was like is this
one
your forehead looks great today
[Laughter]
which disney sidekick or sidekicks
would you most like to join your team
we've got the genie
timon and pumbaa mushu olaf
tinkerbell or cronk genie grants wishes
and also timon and pumbaa love them love
them
i'm going to get i'm going to get the
timon and pumbaa lobby
coming coming at me but they're not the
best sidekicks i mean like they don't
mostly they're preoccupied they you know
they're they're they're really in their
own world it's really about them
you know what i mean that's how i feel
thank you i i i like the genie because
what's wrong with uh having someone
grant you wishes right although i'm with
the genie
did tinker bell grant wishes did she
have some magic
she did some kind of she did it like a
bit of a tick tock dance and then and
then something happened
wait but did she knock the the pumpkin
carriage into like a
cinderella different very man
and i guess it depends on which
tinkerbell talking about because there
was a hook tinkerbell too
right yeah julia roberts tinkerbell yeah
she seemed
more like uh i love you yeah more of
like
robin williams
and uh you know i cut my own um yeah
i'm going genie too i think yeah yeah
oh yeah you know look at that we're all
going to be the same character
i'm i'm i'm going to go to moan and
pumbaa i love the lion king
you know hakuna matata
which separate kingdom in kumandra would
you most like to visit
heart spine fang tail
talon all of them all of them yeah
i feel like fang has the best setup
look at all the cool stuff they got like
school
[Music]
there is that button that says all of
them which is pretty easy but i think
that's too easy but i would
i would want to see fang just because i
want to see what i just want to see what
i built
yeah i guess maybe the better question
is where would you go first
heart hard you got a hearty take a
picture statue statue liberty and then
and then you move on
choose the color that best matches your
personal aura
blue red green purple gray orange
i like i just like the color and by the
way very good coat very good jacket
oh thank you thank you
[Music]
i'm torn between blue and purple i i
think like a deeper blue for me
that blue on there is a little too light
so i don't know
purple kelly kelly what do you think
blue or purple
no i was i oof i think purple's royal i
like the purple
i like the green too but i feel like
it's not green i feel like that's not
green
listen buzzfeed that's not great
green blind yeah my living room is green
as well actually so
uh green clearly green i'm going green
i'm going green
which iconic disney princess
tune would you most want to belt out at
karaoke
part of your world almost there let it
go
reflection when will my life begin
once upon a dream is reflection the one
from mulan
yes yeah that's a really good belting
one
yeah there's there's some belting
moments in that one
you know i think i gotta go with
reflection but also part of your world
though
when i could swim all day and nothing
yeah
yeah i only know one tune and as i'm in
my bathroom i'm going to choose let it
let it go oh dear oh dear
which of the following would be your
weapon of choice in a fight
sword crossbow dagger my fists
blink or the power of friendship i'm
very offended at this picture of fists
um it's like it's like punching the
ceiling
i would choose gemma's fists it looks
like he's just holding something
i'm gonna go sword on this thing
i can't bring a fist to a fist fight am
i
am right i'm going to choose the power
of friendship
because if you think about it no one
gets hurt there's no
you know what i mean each side you don't
need you could bring all those things
no one gets hurt
the power of friendship is kind of like
the all-of-the-above
answer yeah it's the layman's search
what have you guys ever taken
mediation classes
fling shots are not the answer all right
which trait do you value most in others
honesty
loyalty kindness humor generosity
and optimism you do not want them too
honest i'm going loyalty i think on this
loyalty you also don't want them too
optimistic you know what i mean no
because then it's like
get out of get out of my house this is
interesting the question is
you value most in others that's verified
as opposed to your partner your family
your
you mean like so i'm going to go
kindness because i feel like
everything else can kind of flow from
that but what if you're kind but
dishonest
but then but it yeah but no but you're
right because
no no because some people can want to
not be want to be nice
and then lie to you and say that like a
white lie
no i don't know i mean kindness to be to
be polite to be kind
even though you're not polite totally
different i think kindness is the most
hard it's the most difficult trait i
think to find
in human nature people who are truly
kind
i am not particularly kind but i know
really kind people
and i always i'm striving to be more
like that because
it's hard it's really really hard to be
truly kind
because i agree gemma if you are truly
kind it kind of kind of covers all
basics
kindness isn't weakness either
absolutely absolutely not
strength at times to be able to
that's my girl that's my daughter
i've gone for kindness definitely all
right since everyone's doing kindness
i'm going honesty
i got riya
hey uh what can i say you're a certified
badass you're smart spunky and selfish
shirt
your quick wit is only rivaled by your
quick skills with cool weaponry while
you can sometimes be a bit of a loner
you're willing to do whatever it takes
to come to the rescue of your friends
and family am i a bit of a loner yeah
sometimes yeah i agree with most of that
i got raya yeah you and me kelly
yeah i was hoping i would get benjamin
but riot is
i got sisu is definitely an enfp
you're a little bit awkward and a little
bit silly but you're also incredibly
powerful you always try to see the good
in people even when they can't see it in
themselves
your trust and faith in others is your
strength and you inspire all who meet
you
also you're one heck of a slammer i do
know that i am a little bit awkward and
a little bit silly i don't know i don't
always feel very powerful
i got wrong too yeah i think that's uh
it's about right i also got raya i like
being in the heroine
thank you i got sea suit yay
i want to reverse engineer this to find
out how to get benjamin
i can take it to get bunga
you